all right the official cinemasins best
movies of 2015 most we haven't even
started yet
Jesus do you remember the rules what is
this boxing how many times have you done
this you get three strikes I get three
strikes alright this is big rim dude
seriously you're gonna strike my very
first one yeah if it's Pacific Rim yeah
you get strikes too so that's how this
works
I really like that movie that's because
you're stupid the robot drags a cargo
ship through the streets of Hong Kong
and beats up a giant alien monster with
it and I'm sure the Academy will
recognize that when the time comes all
right it's my turn 12 years it's late
seriously oh look at the snobby film
nerd
I saw the slave movie I'm so white and
rich and sorry about everything how do
you say that every year every do not say
that every year
Django Unchained seriously oh look at
the film style
I saw the slave revenge movie I'm so
white and rich sorry about everything
how about the help seriously oh look at
the film snob I saw the civil rights
movie scream too seriously
oh look at the film snob you didn't like
12 years of slave no I liked it I just
got PTSD from it I mean nobody made me
hate myself in a profound way I don't
even think I know what that means
like even a little bit alright my turn
okay World War Z hmm I mean I like that
movie hmm
more than I thought I would even mean
but that's the picture of the year is it
yes way better than that graphic novel
nonsense that was tight I wish it was
easy for me as it is for you to define
the movies quality on tightness as it is
correct you you you I'm striking your
next movie no matter what the hell it is
oh that's mature you'll be happy to know
you just struck captain Phillips I love
that movie I know you do
I'm the captain now you should have
thought about that before you stroke it
without even hearing the title
it's your turn fast and furious 6 what
that movie is terrible I know I know I
know this is a sentimental pic I'm
making this pic for Paul Rudd and Paul
Walker dude we've lost James Gandolfini
and Peter O'Toole this you sure you want
me sentimental pic to go to Paul Walker
alright Paul huh
what does I respect you the strikey
gravity my dick second gravity in
hipster well great
we both use dollar strikes and we don't
have a single movie on our best movies
list
I don't even think I have very many good
options left I don't either and I kind
of like the blue bein frozen was good I
liked the wolf of Wall Street a lot but
it's definitely too long a little too
Goodfellas II but I didn't see her I've
seen a braska I like star trek into
darkness hmm yeah I mean I did too but I
mean we're talking about the best movie
of the year it's Star Trek yeah but that
music though yeah music is the bomb
[Laughter]
[Music]
the
me
[Music]
I think your outfit was awesome dude
you can leave me hanging dude I can't
give you 500 that the space-time
continuum how many times I have to tell
you this I'm like a fist bump
no I can't finger touch you can't touch
you I can't I can't physically touch you
could you please blow on it I totally
fucked